ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคน
คุยขยับเขาอีกอ่ะได้ค่ะ
ขยับนะเที่ยงผู้หญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้วันอังคารวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 ค่ะวันที่ 22 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมเดือนมีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ a คศ
1122 ค่ะ
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
จันทร์ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่
21 ค่ะวันที่ 21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
เดือนมีนาคมนะคะพี่พรรถเท่าไหร่คะ
2565 ปีคศต.ค.เท่าไหร่คะ
2022 วันนี้วันอังคาร
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 วันที่ 23 นะคะแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
บ่าย 3 โมง 12 นาทีค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 12 นาที
นะคะแล้ว
สวัสดีนักเรียนเรามีกี่คน
วันนี้ถึงนักเรียนวันนี้นักเรียนกี่คน
วันนี้นักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9
10  10 คนค่ะ 50 คนนักเรียนยังไม่หนีไป
ใช่ไหมๆสิบคนมามาเรียนทุกวันมากมาดูมามา
ฟังมาเรียนภาษาไทยนะคะคุณผู้หญิงวันนี้
โอ้นี่ครูเอ๋
มีอะไรภาพ
ไม่เห็นไก่ค่ะไม่เห็นเอามีข้าวเป็นกระดาษ
นะคะสี่เหลี่ยม 1  2  3  4 สี่เหลี่ยม
ข้างหน้าเนี่ยมีภาพเดี๋ยวจะให้ครูหญิงดู
จะเห็นไหม
โอเคไหม
เห็นจะมีภาพราคาให้ครูหญิงดูนะคะแล้วครู
เอ๋มีคำถามน้อ
มีคำถามถามครูหญิงคนเดียว
โอเคค่ะนักเรียนใช่โย
ค่ะ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่ถามนักเรียน
ถามครูหญิงคิดว่าไม่ถามนักเรียน
คิดว่าถามขลุ่ยอิงนะคะได้ค่ะเคเอมีเพราะ
ว่าครูเอ๋มีภาพมากๆต้องถามครูหญิงคนเดียว
นะคะค่ะโอเคภาพแรกค่ะคุณหญิงค่ะเห็นไหม
เห็นนะเห็นค่ะ
คือกูเองนะต้องดูภาพด้วยดูครูหญิงด้วยตา
เอกก็จะอยู่ที่พักเปล่า
นะคะผู้หญิงเห็นนะอ่าเห็นท่านะคะเดี๋ยว
คุยคุย
สักครู่นะคะอ่าผู้หญิงเห็นแล้วเนาะอ่า
เห็นค่ะ
อาหารผู้หญิงเห็นแล้วครูเอ๋มีสอบถามค่ะ
เอ่อรูปเนี้ย
เป็นเด็กนะคะเป็นเด็กเด็กผู้ชายหรือเด็ก
ผู้หญิงค่ะเด็กผู้ชายค่ะค่ะรูปนี้เป็น
เด็กผู้ชายอ่ะนะคะอ่ะถ้าเป็นรูปนี้เป็น
เด็กผู้ชายหรือเด็กผู้หญิง
รูปนี้เป็นเด็กผู้หญิงค่ะเด็กผู้หญิงนะคะ
ผู้หญิงคะเด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังทำอะไรคะ
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังปั่นจักรยานค่ะเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังปั่นจักรยาน
พูดปั่นจักรยานโอเคพูดขี่จักรยานโอเคไหม
คะโอเคค่ะ
มีเด็กผู้ชายปั่นจักรยานเด็กผู้ชาย
ขี่จักรยาน
อันไหนอันนี้นะคะจักรยานนะคะจักรยาน
จักรยานมีร้อ
[เพลง]
มรก็มือเนี่ยจับที่แฮนใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะผู้
หญิงปั่นจักรยานปล่อยมือได้หรือไม่ได้
คิดวุ่นหาได้
คิดว่าได้นะปั่นจักรยานแล้วก็
ล้มไหมคะไม่ล้มไม่ล้มน้อเก่งมากครูเอ๋เอ๋
ไม่ได้
รู้เหรอปั่นจักรยานไม่ได้เหรอคะครูเอ๋
ปั่นจักรยานได้แต่ของ EM ปั่นจักรยานแล้ว
ก็ปล่อยมือ
ไม่ได้เอากู f ปั่นจักรยานปล่อยมือล้มนอน
แบบครูเอ๋ปั่นจักรยานได้ปั่นจักรยานได้
ค่ะค่ะเสื้อปั่นจักรยานราคามีผู้หญิงปั่น
จักรยานได้คู๋ปั่นจักรยานได้
ไม่ถามไม่ถามนักเรียนไม่ทันก็ดีขึ้นผู้
หญิงคนเดียวครูหญิงคนเดียวโอเควันนี้ครู
เอ๋ไม่ถามนักเรียนแต่นักเรียนคอมเม้นข้าง
ล่างปั่นจักรยานได้หรือไม่ได้นะคะน้า
เด็กผู้ชายปั่นจักรยานนะคะค่ะต่อไปค่ะนิ
เห็นชัดไหมเห็นค่ะเห็นซัคเกอร์
อ่ะ
โอเคโอเคปิด
ผู้หญิงรูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชาย
รูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิงค่ะเด็กผู้หญิงกำลังทำ
มีอะไรคะเด็กผู้หญิงกำลังนอน
เด็กผู้หญิงกำลังนอนนะคะ R เด็กผู้หญิง
อันนี้อะไรคะผู้หญิงหมอนค่ะหมอนอันนี้
อะไรคะถ้าห่มอันนี้อะไรคะเตียงนอนแล้วอัด
ที่มือเด็กผู้หญิงมีอะไรคะตุ๊กตาค่ะ
ตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาเป็นรูปอะไรคะตุ๊กตาหมีหมี
Teddy  Bear หรือเปล่าเสร็จดีแบงค์ตาหมี
เด็กผู้หญิงนอนยิ้ม Who
นอนดีมหน้านะคะครูหญิง
มันกินปั่นจักรยานได้ผู้หญิงชอบนอนไหมคะ
ครูหญิงตัว Top นอนมากๆค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบนอนไหมคะครูเอ๋ก็ชอบนอนแต่กู
เอนนอนนิดหน่อยมึงกลายคู๋ชอบดูซีรีย์แล้ว
ก็หลับ
นะออยเด็กผู้หญิง
นอนนะคะผ่านนอน OK ต่อไป
กูอย่างนี้รูปเยอะค่ะ
รูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชาย
รูปนี้เด็กผู้ชายค่ะเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังทำอะไรคะ
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังว่ายน้ำหาเด็กผู้ชายกำลัง
ว่ายน้ำอันนี้เป็นน้ำไม่ใช่ไหมค่ะอันนี้
ใช่ครั้งน้ำเด็กผู้ชายใส่เสื้อไหมเสื้อ
เด็กเด็กผู้ชายไม่ได้ใส่เสื้อ
เด็กผู้ชายใส่กางเกงไหมคะเด็กผู้ชายไม่
ได้ใส่กางเกง
แล้วเด็กผู้ชายใส่อะไรคะเด็กผู้ชายใส่
กางเกงว่ายน้ำ
ไม่ได้ใส่กางเกงแบบนี้เนาะกางเกงอันนี้
ไม่ใส่ใส่กางเกง
ว่ายน้ำนะคะอันนี้ว่ายน้ำแล้วคะไหว้ครู
ผู้หญิงว่ายน้ำ
ได้ไหมคะครูหญิงว่ายน้ำไม่ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ว่ายน้ำได้ไหมคะอ่ะ
สระ
ว่ายน้ำได้นิดหน่อย
โอเคหน่อยไม่เก่งนะคะแต่ว่ายน้ำได้นะคะ
เด็กผู้ชายก็ว่ายน้ำนะคะ
[เพลง]
เอกชอบว่ายน้ำขอ
ว่ายน้ำไม่ได้แต่ชอบน้ำไหมคะ
ชอบน้ำค่ะแต่ไม่ว่ายน้ำไม่ว่ายน้ำ
ผู้หญิงก็ไปทะเล
ไม่ได้
ทะเลและผู้หญิงว่าทะเลให้หน่อย
ภูเก็ตฮาวายมัลดีฟนี่ทะเลทีนะว่าน้าทะเล
อะไรตรงนี้ก็ได้นะกูเองกูเองว่ายน้ำ
อาจจะคู่หญิงไม่ได้หมายถึงไปทะเลโอเคไหม
โอเค
ดูครูเอ๋ว่ายน้ำ
ผู้หญิงนางธิมีเรือไหมคะว่าเรือ
ผู้หญิงว่าวาดเรือ
ผู้หญิงว่าเรือนะคะเหลือและผู้หญิงนั่ง
ที่เรือ
โอเคไหมคะ
ไม่โอเคค่ะทำไมกลัวผู้หญิงว่ายน้ำไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงไปเรียนว่ายน้ำ
โอเคค่ะ
ผู้หญิงต้องเรียนว่ายน้ำนะหน้า
2023 ครูโรงเรียนว่ายน้ำโอเคไหมคะครูเอ๋
ไม่ต้องตอนนี้
2022 เอา 2022
ต้องเรียนว่ายน้ำเพราะมูลผู้หญิงนั่ง
เครื่องบินเครื่องบินไม่ใช่เรือนะ
[เพลง]
เครื่องบินใช่ไหม
อ่ะเครื่องบินโอเคไหมโอเค
กูหญิงนั่งเครื่องบินก็ต้องเรียนว่ายน้ำ
โอโห้
เครื่องบิน
ผู้หญิงให้หนาวยังไงไม่ได้ช่วยดู
ไม่เป็นไรผู้หญิงผู้หญิงต้องก้มมาตัด
เครื่องบินก้มแล้วก็หยิบข้อ
ต่อใส่
หน้าสีสีทนะสีเหลือง
แล้วก็หญิงก็ใส่แล้วก็ดึง
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ลอยชูชีพโอเค
ไม่ตาย
ๆออแต่คุยอิ๋งว่ายน้ำไม่ได้นะคะไอ้ได้ค่ะ
ต่อไปค่ะ
โอเครูปต่อไปเด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชาย
เด็กผู้ชายค่ะเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังทำอะไรคะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังเดินเด็กผู้
ชายกำลังเดินนะคะครูหญิงเดิน
ไม่ใช่ใช่ไหมใช้ค่ะผู้หญิงเดินด้ายคู่
หญิงชอบเดินไหมคะ
โชคเดินค่ะอ๋อชอบเดินนะคะครูเอ๋ชอบเดิน
ไหมคะ R ครูเอ๋ก็ชอบเดินห่วงแต่ไม่ได้
เดิน
แต่เอกเดินชอบๆเดินชอบเดินที่ช้อปปิ้งอีก
เหมือนกันเหมือนกันชอบเดิน Super  market
Shopping
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตชอบเดินผู้หญิงมีไว้บอด
อ่ะค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบเอ้าทะเล
เอ้า
เพราะครูเอ๋
The  Best ชอบเดินทะเลหรอคะถ้าไม่เป็นไร
วัดใหม่ได้ค่ะน้ำ 5
ทะเลทะเลครูเอ๋ชอบเดิน
กับฉันก็ครูเอ๋
เดินๆไม่ว่ายน้ำเดินไปเดินมาเดินไปเดินมา
เดินไปเดินมา
เอกชอบมากเดิน
โอเคต่อไปค่ะ
อันนี้ก่อนมันกินตื่นใช่มะอันนี้ค่ะเด็ก
ผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้หญิงค่ะเด็ก
ผู้หญิงกำลังทำอะไรคะ
เด็กผู้หญิงกำลังนั่งหาดเด็กผู้หญิงกำลัง
นั่ง
มีผู้หญิงนั่งที่ไหนคะเด็กผู้หญิงนั่งที่
เก้าอี้ค่ะอ่านั่งที่เก้าอี้หรือนั่งบน
เก้าอี้โอเคเนาะอันบนเก้าอี้แล้วอันนี้
อะไรคะนกค่ะนกเอานกเด็กผู้หญิงนั่ง
เก้าอี้แล้วก็ทำอะไรกับนก
คุยคุยกับนกหนูคือกำลังคุยคุยคุยกับนก
เด็ก
ผู้หญิงชอบนั่งไหม
ชอบนั่งค่ะ
รู๋
ชอบนั่งไว้คะเอกก็ชอบนั่งค่ะ
เดินๆเหนื่อยก็นั่ง
ใส่ขาดโอเคปรับไปมีนั่งเนาะอ่ะแต่ไม่เป็น
ไรคุยกำลังหาอีก 1 ลูกอยู่ตัวเองหารูป
อะไรก็ดีมีเดินนั่งนอนใช่ไหมคะอันนี้เด็ก
ผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายค่ะเด็ก
ผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังวิ่ง
เอาวิ่งอ๋ออ๋อมิมีเส้นอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะชน
เปี่ยนเด็กผู้ชายกำลังวิ่งผู้หญิงครูหญิง
ชอบวิ่งไหมครูหญิงไม่ชอบวิ่งค่ะผู้หญิง
ไม่ชอบวิ่งครูเอ๋ชอบวิ่งไหมคะ
ครูอะไรท่อบค่ะอ่ะก็เหนื่อย
ๆ
ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋ชอบ the  Turn ที่ทะเลครูเข
ไม่วิ่งไม่วิ่งที่ทะเลเหรอคะไอ้วิ่งครู
เอ๋ไม่ชอบวิ่งกูเอ๋ชอบว่ายน้ำ
แต่ตอนนี้ที่ที่นี่ Condo  Condominium
ไม่ว่ายน้ำ
โคบิตเอาทรายทรายๆ
ก็เด็กผู้ชายวิ่งนะคะกำลังวิ่งหรือวิ่ง
ใส่นะคะ
จะไปค่ะ
รูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชายคะเด็ก
ผู้ชายค่ะเด็กผู้ชาย
คุณกำลังทำอะไรคะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังปลอมให้
ร้องไห้ทำไม
ทำไมร้องไห้เด็กที่หัวเด็กผู้ชายเจ็บบ่
ที่หัวสีแดงๆอันนี้หัวนะฮะหัวแล้วก็ตรง
นี้เรียกอะไรนะหน้าผากหน้าผากหน้าผากเด็ก
ผู้ชาย
บวมนี่รวมนะเนี่ยเห็นไหมบวมเห็นคิดว่า
เด็กผู้ชายวิ่งแล้วก็ล้มแล้วก็บวมสีแดง
แล้วเจ็บเหรอคะเจ็บค่ะแล้วก็เด็กผู้ชาย
เจ็บก็
มะเหงผู้หญิงนักเรียนไม่เข้าใจเจ็บปวด
ท่านผู้หญิงทำอะไรกูหญิงตีแขนเจ็บอ๊อดปี
อุ้ยไม่ได้ยินเสียงตีเอาเอกฟังของคุยได้
ได้ยิน
เจ็บเจ็บ
เจ็บนักเรียนเข้าใจเนาะ
นักเรียนพยักหน้าค่ะเข้าใจถ้านักเรียนไม่
เข้าใจนักเรียนเอามือแล้วก็หยิก
หยิบตัวเอง
เจ็บเก็บ
เด็กผู้ชายใช่มะเจ็บหัวเจ็บหน้าผากก็ร้อง
ไห้มี
ผู้หญิงชอบร้องไห้ไหมไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเหรอ
through  a ชอบร้องไห้ไหมคะ
สู้โอ๋เอ๋ไม่ชอบเธออ่ะว่าจะร้องอะ
มือ
ครู A7 โอยยร้องให้
ครูเอ๋ดูซีรีย์แล้วเรื่องเหอะขอ
ร้องให้
เด็กๆร้องไห้นะคะผู้หญิงเมื่อก่อนกู้หญิง
ร้องไห้ไหมเมื่อกี้ร้องไห้ค่ะค่ะเมื่อ
ก่อนผู้หญิงเด็กๆร้องให้ครูเอ๋นะร้องไห้
มีเสียง
ครูหญิงร้องไห้มีเสียงไหม
ครูหญิงร้องไห้
มีเสียงเลยค่ะซูมตัด
ยังไงเนี่ยๆ
[เพลง]
แน่
นอนๆๆซูมกับเสียงผู้หญิงเสียงแงแงๆๆฮือ
ครูเอ๋
คือ
นะคะเวลาแย่ๆ
โอเคกับเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังร้องไห้นะคะ
เพราะว่าจะเจ็บใช่มั้ยหัวเจ็บหน้าผากต่อ
ไปอันนี้ครูหญิงต้องชอบหนู
อะไรคะรูปอะไร
รูปนี้เด็กผู้ชายหรือเด็กผู้หญิงคะครู
หญิงเด็กผู้ชายค่ะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไร
คะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังกินเด็กผู้ชายกำลังกิน
ราคา้
มีเด็กผู้ชายมีมือสองมือมือนี้ถือใช่มั้ย
ถือถืออะไรคะถือช้อนค่ะถือช้อนนะมื้อนี้
ถืออะไรคะถือส้อมค่ะถือส้อมนะคะช้อนเขา
ตัดอะไรคะ
ข้าวค่ะช้อนตักข้าวอนิมิข้าวมีผักมีไข่
ดาวมีแก้วนักแก้วแล้วก็มีน้ำแก้วน้ำโต๊ะ
อาหารโต๊ะแล้วก็เก้าอี้เด็กผู้ชายนั่งบน
เก้าอี้แล้วก็ถือช้อนตัดข้าว
กินกินนะคะอะค่ะอันนี้เด็กผู้ชายกำลังกิน
นี้นะคะกินอะไรคะกินข้าวค่ะกินข้าวครู
หญิงชอบกินไหมคะครูหญิงชอบกินมากๆ
ชอบกินมากๆครูเอ๋ชอบกินไหมคะครูเอ๋
ไม่ชอบหรอ
ชอบค่ะ
จะไม่บัคบ้างเออเมื่อก่อนชอบกินมากๆตอน
นี้กินโอเคถึง
อันนี้กินนะคะกิน
มีเวลาไหมมีค่ะยังมีเวลาค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้
ดูเวลานะคะทั้งผู้หญิงต้องบอกครูเอ๋นะ
โอเคค่ะต่อไปกินก็ต้องมีก็ทำอาหารนะคะ
อันนี้เด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้ชายชายทัศน์
เด็กผู้หญิงค่ะเด็กผู้หญิงเด็กผู้หญิง
กำลังทำอะไรคะเด็กผู้หญิงกำลังทำอาหาร
เด็กผู้หญิงกำลังทำอาหารอ่าอันนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรคะ
กระทะค่ะละอันนี้เด็กผู้หญิงถืออะไรคะ
ตะหลิวค่ะนะริ้วแล้วก็ใส่อะไรไม่รู้ใส่
ซอสเนาะอ๊อดเด็กผู้หญิงกำลัง
ทำอาหาร
ทำอาหารเอาคิดว่าขัดเนาะค่ะเราก็พูดทำ
อาหารโอเคค่ะ
ครูผู้หญิงชอบทำอาหาร
อยู่ในคะครูหญิงไม่ชอบทำอาหารค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบทำอาหารไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบทำอาหาร
นี่บ้ามากมากมาย
โอเคนะโอเคให้มากโอเคมาก
ชอบทำอาหารมากมากๆๆก็เอ๋กอล์ฟมือเหมือน
เด็กผู้หญิงทำอาหารนะคะใจก่อนโอเค
ผู้หญิงคะรูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิงหรือเด็กผู้
ชายเด็กผู้หญิงค่ะอ้าเด็กผู้หญิงที่รูป
นี้มีเด็กผู้หญิงและอันนี้อะไรคะ
เค้กค่ะอันนี้อะไรคะ
อาจานค่ะจานอยู่ที่ไหนคะจานการเค้กอยู่
ที่ไหนคะจานเค้กอยู่บนโต๊ะค่ะปิดโต๊ะกู
อยู่บนโต๊ะอาบนเค้กมีอะไรคะมีเทียนค่ะ
เทียนแล้วเทียนตรงนี้เป็นอะไรคะไปค่ะอ๋อ
อ๋อเขาจุดไฟ
ไม่มีแล้วนะมีที่รักก็จุด
นะมีไฟนะคะมือเค้กนะเด็กผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะ
เด็กผู้หญิงกำลังเป่าค่ะกำลังเป่าอะไรเรา
เป่าเทียนอ่าเดะอันนี้เทียนนะคะเด็กผู้
หญิงเป่าเทียนอ่ะแล้วไฟก็เป็นยังไงคะ
ไปดับนาง
ก็
เอา
กิน erh ทิชชู่แล้วก็
ผู้หญิงเป่าที่สู้จะเด็กผู้หญิงเป่าเทียน
นะครับเป่าเทียน
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงชอบเป่าเทียนไหม
ถึงไม่ชอบเป่าเทียนค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบเป่าเทียนไหมคะคุณเอกก็ไม่ชอบ
เป่าเทียนมูเอไม่ชอบเค้ก
แต่เด็กชอบเขเหมือนชอบเป่าเทียนไม่ค่ะครู
เอ๋คะวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเอ้าหมดเวลาแล้ว
โอเคงั้นกูอ่ะทบทวนหนึ่งครั้งนะคะอันนี้
เป็นเป็นคำอาจเป็นอะไรนะคะ
เป่า
เป่านะคะอ่าอันนี้ภาพนี้ทำอะไรคะทำอาหาร
ค่ะทำอาหาร
อ่ะเด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะกินกิน
เด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังทำอะไรคะน้องเฮาให้ร้องไห้เด็กผู้
ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะวิ่ง
วิ่งนะคะ
เด็กตรงนี้นะเด็กผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะนั่งปุ๊บ
นั่งมหา
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะเดินเดิน
มี
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะว่ายน้ำลายน้ำ
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะที่จักรยานขี่
จักรยานและเด็กผู้หญิงทำอะไร
นอนนอนโอเคหมดเวลาค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋อย่าลืม
อีกไว้เจอกัน
EP2 นะกะ
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]